alors quand berri nous a proposé claude
berri nous a proposés vous ai fait un
peu votre chauffeur du bus mais comment
vous savez tout ça ça fait pas ce que je
peux vous le faire à chaque question
mais c'est ce que je ferai à chaque fois
merci aux enfants je vous demande de
vous injectez voilà vous avez fait un
peu la chochotte non c'est vrai pourquoi
que j'étais en train d'écrire un
scénario que je pensais bon kebab on est
donc j'ai dit non je suis en train
d'écrire un truc donc non j'ai pas envie
de faire astérix ne répond plus la bande
dessinée c'est quand même votre truc
j'adore j'ai tout de suite parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est que
la première ambition d'alain chabat
quand il vivait à massy après que sa
famille ait quitté oran
alain chabat le petit pied noir exilés
rêver des toiles disney oui malric
alors c'est vrai nom vous êtes branché
bande dessinée depuis toujours bien sûr
je voulais être successeur de walt
disney quand j'étais petit j'avais même
mis ça sur profession plus tard je crois
au cm1
parquet c'est pas ça peut arriver parce
que maintenant on vu le succès que vous
avez vous connaissez 400 berck tous ces
mecs là ouais je tutoie les plus grands
vins
ça peut arriver alors l'avantagé quand
même du premier astérix c'est comme ça a
posé un peu les personnages ça a permis
quand même de voir qu'on pouvait faire
astérix au cinéma vous arriver là dessus
après je dirais que c'est un petit peu
plus facile de déconner au deuxième
absolument nécessaire pour faire plaisir
avec l'audi quand même non mais c'est
vrai que mêmes mais je veux dire
depardieu clavier accepter des rôles
comme ça c'est quand même d'aider rôle
c'est très très improbable jouer un
petit goût doit comme ça avec un drone
et les moustaches etc
alors bon pourquoi ça nous plaît parce
que là il ya des influences qui équipe
qui me plaisent de toute façon ce mel
brooks comme influences il ya mike myers
et les monty python il ya zac
ce qu'ils ont fait y at il un pilote
dans l'avion bien les nuls il ya les
1000 bien sûr il ya jean yanne deux
heures moins le quart avant jésus christ
et sylves et 2000 il ya des scènes
laisser ça là des scènes ce que c'est
genre
[Musique]
allumée
mais dieu
c'est tout l'esprit du film c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas vu le film
piétons
d'y aller alors il ya des gags somptueux
que je vais pas raconter bien entendu
non non c'est pourri il ya pas mal de
références il ya des passages en dessin
animé qui sont très très bien fait
j'espère que c'est quand même une
histoire on regarde quand même un film
d'astérix et obélix oui ce que j'ai
j'adore quand même perdre par dessus
tout goscinny et uderzo dans une
meilleure phase à mais c'est vrai que
les enfants verront un film d'astérix et
obélix et les vieux enfants comme nous
verrons attendons voir pour la part j'ai
vu une belle merde sortie avant la fin
voilà rugby alors tout ça a commencé à
un cheval le jour où vous avez réalisé
qu'on a le droit finalement et c'est
vous qui le dites de finir une bagarre
dans le studio du film qui tourne à côté
un jour aperçu de sa non mais c'est vrai
que moi y'a des trucs qui m'ont mis des
gifles comme le shérif est en prison
mais effectivement de mel brooks de ben
ouais effectivement il ya une bagarre de
saloon qui finit dans un autre studio
cinéma il ya des grosses allure duffy
danse avec avec des plume dans le cul 20
semaines de tournage quand même hein
vous êtes un vrai patron il paraît pas
que vous êtes viré ça avec beaucoup de
bons toujours très perfectionniste
évidemment et beaucoup de calme
ouais je suis plus ça dépend des jours
mais en général je suis pas super
nerveux mais c'est la drogue beaucoup
qui fait ça pendant l'endroit où je suis
là je le raconte quand même il reste
presque plus de potion magique dans la
petite fiole darmon qui fait ça si
l'écran est il fait
si dans leur ventre normal
les gens racontent pas d'autres biens
matin alors oui non vous êtes tellement
calme et ou qui vous appeler son
tournage casse-cou x tranquille x ah bon
oui vous savez pas si vous n'avez pas
une invention south et c'est vrai ou ses
fruits c'est vrai vous saviez pas non
servirait pas non chaque casque ou x
tranquille x bah ouais mais ça me va
bien et jamel josé des fêtes tous les
soirs lui n'en faisait pas des fêtes
tous les soirs c'est une légende il
faisait des fêtes le en général le
vendredi soir ou le samedi soir 1 samedi
soir au maroc puisse contourner 6 jours
sur 7 5 le samedi soir il y avait de
toute façon une teuf qui était organisé
par où les où les comédiens ou un
comédien ou les costumes ou les décors
et ses goûts musicaux qui ont aussi
applaudi de toronto le mardi 13 mercredi
le jeudi 1 tous les jeudis et puis après
le week end vendredi samedi dimanche
normal moi j'ai raté tout ça de moi
j'allais à celle du samedi soir mais bah
oui vous êtes bien marré a complètement
pour moi j'étais au turbin ça a duré
longtemps en plus sa durée 22e semaine
ou
bien alors sorti dans 950 salle ces
normes oui oui
c'est une grosse sortie c'est sûr c'est
une très très grosse sortie déjà vendu
aux usa j'étais là par miramax me voilà
g x miramas et dans le reste du monde
bientôt non le reste du monde à acheter
comme le premier à marcher vraiment
partout en europe
mais il vous le dira jamais mais c'est
vrai qu'il a abattu un travail colossal
au c'est un travail colossal de faire le
film il a il a bossé comme incroyable
façon il est il est né pour sa ville a
bossé comme un quoi jean
combes une réponse amiable
alors jouer avec la pression toujours de
faire un court métrage quoi ça qui était
incroyable alors vous en faite un jour
vous dînez avec votre ami vincent lindon
oui et vincent vous dit tu sais que
chabat prépare son astérix ne vient pas
et je ne sais pas pourquoi mais qui
fument gt gt dans ma bulle entre autres
j'étais dans ma bulle où elle ajouté
j'étais un peu absent dépôts que j'ai ça
se passait bon ça n'allait pas trop bien
ça arrive dans la vie pourquoi de
publicité quoi alors je vais t'expliquer
exactement où j'en étais sûr sens du
rythme on n'a pas toujours non mais
c'est un sentimental d'arbres alors vous
appeler alain chabab lui dit alors non
je dis pas alors je viens à l'instant je
veux prendre un petit café avec toi et
me dit ok de blaye
fiat période
ouais voilà je dit j'aimerais bien faire
partie de cette aventure je sais pas
quoi et très franchement je dis toujours
entre la fin de ma question et sa
réponse il s'est passé quoi j'ai pas une
seconde nuit quoi on parle il ad je ne
sais pas dans quoi ouais je suis
d'accord voilà il a tenté de l'appeler
parce qu'autant je n'ai pas aimé le film
est autant j'ai trouvé gérard forme et
bien je trouve que vraiment il crève
l'écran et il a appréhendé ce rôle de
méchant d'une façon fantastique et je
trouve qu'il réhabilite un peu le fil
mais cette débauche d'effets spéciaux ce
dégueulis de fric
ceci étant
c'est vrai que le personnage droit
ordinaire dans le film c'est beaucoup du
bourg de vous déguiser comme ça et
surtout vous avez inventé un personnage
qui est le premier reptile humain oui
et ça s'est décidé la veille du tournage
oui c'est comme ça c'est dans l'est dans
les dents dans les affres de l'acteur
qui va qui sépare les infos de l'acteur
c'est le haschich du maroc dit la vérité
aussi ça veut dire ça on a l'accord
vous avez inventé ce truc d'une espèce
de rire sifflement comme ça oui je suis
dit tiens comment comment conquérir
perso ce 6e mais qu'il est bon c'est un
méchant ça c'est un méchant raison qu'il
est quelqu'un qui skie qu'est-ce qui
doit bien rire un bon donc voilà comment
irrigué de le faire j'ai obligé
pas payer ça fait moins bien
[Musique]
vous avez souffert parce que ce tournage
en plein désert 45° des frais 55 degrés
centigrades vous dites les bijoux
chauffer on a eu des fous rires dit de
chaleur on est des fous rires de chaleur
oui parce qu'on avait on avait la tête
pleine de quoi c'est plus de cerveau il
devait faire à peu près 50 50 c'est fou
14h dans des heurts à ouarzazate en
plein mois de jeûne c'est quoi il
faisait 45 1 sous la tente de ces arrêts
mais de la biogue de l'agent gala une
équipe de cinéma les projos les
flambeaux
c'était infernal et en plus les bouger
les bougies et les bijoux
voilà nous sommes tous ces mois chabal
acteurs qui se droguent
série conducteur est serré pendant lés
prises je me brûler les doigts ou ont
simplement luisant au mont césar et la
somme ont colligé il rien n'est venu
déjà du bruit
et or après quand vous êtes rentré en
europe en studio on vous a obligé à
jouer la scène avec jamel où vous
marchez sur les murs enfin comme dans
les films de hong kong voilà sur les
colonnes et tout ça avec défendu pendu a
parfois la mort en hiver pas de
chauffage demande lui a dit m et foin
cinoche
1-1 coûte à chaud c'est ça qui est beau
en même temps c'est d'abord le travail
dans la maj l'industrie du rêve
le meilleur souvenir du tournage alain
c'est quoi ça parle de cacher là on
parle alors
non c'est le franchement c'est le tourne
super mauvais en anecdotes mais c'est
vrai que c'est le tournage c'est le
l'humeur générale mais bon le meilleur
souvenir c'est le tournage le plus
mauvais souvenir le plus mauvais
souvenir c'est le
c'est pas des mauvais souvenirs mais
c'est vrai que j'ai dirigé une ou deux
scènes des chiottes parce que je m'étais
pris une vraie bonne tourista et donc je
suis auto qui dans les chiottes assis
sur le moniteur de contrôle même pas le
moniteur de contrôle et l'assistant qui
fait ces prêts tu veux vérifier je fais
non c'est bon ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu